I have a son my son's having his first
birthday do you want come you're having
a November 3rd my house we're having a
one-year-olds birthday party I you know
I appreciate the invitation I have to
imagine it's like a it's gonna be
awesome it's it's you think the video
well I for him it won't matter he won't
remember it right so I started off I all
right we better get some kids food and
then I realized I didn't know anyone
else with kids so it's just a whole lot
of adults staying around the one you're
going yeah right so we got like a bouncy
castle because I thought it would be a
kid's party but now no kids are showing
up right there there's got to be a coke
room ah is that Australian for something
yeah yeah I just mispronounced the word
cloak um do you love cloaking when you
have a child people always say that tea
they go they go I'll forget about it
you're never sleeping again
that's over you're never gonna sleep
right yes tell you something about
having a baby way easier than a coke
habit ah yeah Lisa's not me who wakes up
crying anymore
I can put up with I can sleep through
other people crying I'd go for it yeah
yeah I feel like I've ruined my career
no oh your son is turning one we did it
out this is my son's it yeah it's the
problem the problem with him being my
son's a loser is why I haven't no he
really is why he's best friends ease mum
hey if you meet any guys like all of my
mum she's like my best friend that's it
that's a freaking loser all right but he
still lives at home hasn't moved out
loser if you've got kids no I don't have
any cards it's an exciting way to ruin a
relationship I am
I went when the girl stops breastfeeding
yeah the tits go like rock-hard kind of
like a tempurpedic mattress it's you
could put a glass oh one and punch the
other one in the line ones yeah
so they give our nerd punch breasts
nobody ever who does that that's
ridiculous